since the british brought tea to what
was then salon the workers barely
changed
producing one of the world's most
refreshing drinks still takes
painstaking manual labor
plucking the leaves by hand
but for sri lanka's tea pickers life has
become even tougher as its economy
collapses
we don't know what will happen in the
future
we have food to eat today but we don't
know about tomorrow
it's hard to live right now
this month we manage but we don't know
about the next
bit
for a century and a half these hills
have kept the world in tea
it may still look idyllic but sri
lanka's tea plantations are in deep
trouble
production is halved and planters say
the country's economic crisis could
finish off the industry
i'm of course worried because we don't
know what will happen to us also
not only from the top to bottom is going
to suffer with because of these several
decisions what are you afraid of what's
the worst thing that can happen
worst things happen the
world is going to lost the salon tea
global economic problems soaring fuel
prices inflation the pandemic are all to
blame but the crisis is homegrown too
the tea planters problems began when the
government banned the use of chemical
fertilizers almost overnight the
decision has decimated agricultural
production bankrupted the country and
led to massive unrest
[Applause]
unrest that goes on while sri lanka's
deep economic problems remain unsolved
the country is bankrupt and running out
of the bare necessities of life
while one of its most iconic and
lucrative industries could go out of
business
dominic waghorn sky news
up country in sri lanka